we've got a fantastic panel that the
panels call star tech Enterprise and
suitably enough we've got a set of set
of stars before you today we have to my
right I'm going to they've all got very
impressive resumes I'm gonna try not to
forget any of them I really love my
phone this is this is Karina Nami rhymes
with army she told me a rising star of
British biotech Karina is founder and
CEO of hellix nanos she attended a
singularity University which for those
of you don't know is this incredible
place on the NASA base in California
right to the middle of Silicon Valley
then we've got Jamal Edwards Jamal is as
I'm sure all of you know when a
Britain's most successful young
entrepreneurs he revolutionized the
music industry with his YouTube channel
SB TV which broke acts like Ed Sheeran
scary enough Jamal pointed out to me in
the beginning when we bumped into each
other's David he started SB TV 10 years
ago when he was 14 which is pretty damn
impressive
we have Katherine Parsons co-founder and
CEO of decoded technology education
company teaching code data and hacking
to thousands of professionals worldwide
and changing entire interesting washes
that's it
Julie Mayer founder and CEO of adrian
capital and author of welcome to
entrepreneur country i think we're in
the middle of entrepreneur e right here
and and of course we have with us roman
we can introduce yourself very well as
the as a CEO of o2 powering
so much of what's good in there
so let's let's let's kick off maybe
maybe with you
Julie there's a lot of talk right now
about startup so it used to be the case
in Britain that we were worried that we
didn't have enough of her an
entrepreneurial culture enough of her I
fear to fail she think maybe the
pendulum swung too far what do you think
about this the craze around start to try
that what was great to see Martha here
just a couple minutes ago because the
very first internet deal that I did was
helping getting brenton Martha funded we
did the first six million sterling
investment in them in 1998 and it's true
that when new media investors put in the
money and then when we raise that next
round with and for them there weren't a
lot of last-minute coms out there that
we're competing which is and they were
so spectacular and exceptional anyway
but I think the important point about
your question is have we shifted to a
different stage of the game and a lot of
our thinking at Ariadne capital and our
whole ecosystem economics methodology is
really based on the work of Carlota
Perez and I really encourage if you
don't know who Carlota Perez is you
should actually if you're in the room
because what she says is that this is
not about disruptive technology at all
that moment was about 1970 and every 60
to 80 years the same thing happens which
is really kind of reassuring because it
means you don't have to understand the
cosmos you just actually have to read
history we're in the second half of the
cycle where non technology incumbents
and technology players are pulling those
derivative technologies in and embedding
them so we moved from a moment of Big
Bang microprocessor all that stuff to a
new common sense so it's true that
there's a huge competition of those
digital enablers to get into partnership
with the o2s and all of the other big
companies right now it's hard to say if
it's too many hmm Jamal you
youngest people ever took an MBE
services to entrepreneurship and music
what you'll take on starting a company
and growing a company I think the
biggest thing for me when I was 15 was I
didn't really have the infrastructure to
sort of take it to the next level but
now I'm sort of learning and getting
more sort of help from government and
different wants and finding the right
team or I mean to actually take it to
the next level possible I already if I
think when I'm not going to schools and
speaking to the kids the biggest thing
that I talk to them about is that tax
v80 and then how to vote your company
because that's the biggest thing that we
don't get taught in school and that's
the biggest thing that can also affect
official business but now it's just
about putting a right team around me but
when I first thought I thought feels
quite daunting because I was in if an
either that I kind of try and find to
help me grow us btv so I just learn it
all from the internet yeah how to
hoodwink the taxman should be like I
think you've worked and built companies
in America and the UK what would you say
is it the sort of difference in between
these two scenes now how different is it
wow that's a big question um many
differences ISO I originally grew up in
London but my first experience of being
an entrepreneur was in San Francisco and
I learnt a lot from the culture there
there's a real open sharing of ideas so
people aren't scared to talk about their
ideas they understand that ideas are
plentiful but execution is hard and that
open sharing creates this real community
where people help each other out people
are much less risk-averse as we've heard
over and over again they understand that
failure is really experienced and
learnings that can be applied to the
next the next venture there's also I
think one of the difficulties in the UK
is around
Capital is around funding so last year
and startups in the UK raised about
seven billion dollars startups in the
u.s. raised about forty billion dollars
that's a very very big difference it is
improving here so I think this year
Soros thought he was 40% growth on last
year but until companies in the UK have
the kind of aggressive firepower that
they need to expand globally and to make
really big risky bets it's going to be
hard for us to compete the UK the
American economy and population is four
five times bigger than the UK's is that
okay because we're we're
english-speaking and so we can address
this global market we have incredible
technical universities there's a great
deal of talent here and that I think is
being underutilized and we could really
be a global power in terms of the
digital revolution and being a big part
of that picture you know punching bigger
than our population size but making use
of the fact that we sit in a very unique
position from Chile on the startup
culture right now and the change in
equilibrium Jammal about how things seem
to have got easier for people to to
build build companies but but also maybe
just now that there's still some way to
go Katherine and if you were if you're
in government I know what what things
would you do to try and move the needle
to help making experience mean three
years ago I think if you told your
parents that you wanted to be an
entrepreneur I think you look horrified
whereas at least now there seems to be a
kind of a sense of entrepreneurship
being a good thing and actually the
environment being less risky than it was
maybe three or four years ago a lot of
people putting
into creasing incubate spaces and
digital resources that can tell you
where to go to raise money but I think
it's just the beginning you know we've
been like we've talked about 40
different cities teaching coding in the
last year and actually got a real flavor
as you know we've been going around the
globe of kind of we're just you know the
UK sit within the context of
entrepreneurship and and actually I
think it's one of the best places to
start a business and but there's so much
more that can be done in terms of really
believing that globally world-changing
businesses can be born out of the UK so
continue to invest in digital skills as
Martha said that are coming out of all
universities but also at that career
change stage of people's lives so when
they're seven when they're 17 when
they're 27 when they're 70 and continue
to create an environment that is
frictionless when it comes from idea
right through to investment right
through to execution so that anyone who
has an idea that comes to gobble it down
on a piece of paper knows what Avenue
and what journey they can go on to make
that a reality
you run where the biggest companies
around does all this talk of startups
and it's not ups being more innovative
than big companies and what does that
certainly you do you think that's
assuming that's true the other tool is
the founders have one of the most
successful incubators in the in the
world in wire we're more than happy to
be part of the equation
I think the exam question is and if we
look at the UK and what's happened over
the last few years you've seen a
doubling and the number of accelerator
and incubator programs in the UK between
2011 2014 we've also seen that the
statistics of businesses that go through
those we did research last year says
they're 12 percent more likely to
survive
that's between 78 percent approximately
of an ordinary startup that hasn't been
through and 90 percent for those who go
through and they also raise more money
in their earlier rounds I think the
challenge that we
have is from startup to scale-up and I
think that's where the markets in the US
are definitely more mature in my view so
what I think we we have two challenges
in the UK at the moment as I would see
it we have a real north/south divide we
have to address more than two-thirds of
the programs are based in the southeast
and predominantly based in London I
think some of the current government's
policies around northern powerhouse
might help us to shift some of the
balance of that and then I think the
second thing is how do we move from
startup to scale-up and I think that's
what corporates can help one of the
interesting growth areas is 12% of the
programs that are in the UK now are
actually corporate sponsored programs
and Julie and I were just talking as we
came in having the opportunity for a
startup to work with a big established
business may be part of the secret of
how they scale up very very different
cultures interacting between startup and
and a big company how did you possibly
have to such different entities
communicating properly whether sure
what's the trick to making that one in
in our case we're very clear we keep our
our wider startup and outside the
business but we give it all the access
it wants to the business and I think
that's quite an important principle it
stands alone but has access to whatever
it wants and what we aspire to do is to
find the next Facebook's and whatever as
everybody else does but we also want to
cross-fertilize back into our own
business and rediscover how big
companies can be innovative so I
actually have first-hand experience of
that with with helix nano we're working
with Johnson & Johnson which is a
massive pharmaceutical company of course
and it's all about setting up the right
structure where as the start of you can
take what you need from that environment
without feeling vulnerable or without
kind of giving away your secret sauce
and I think a lot of big companies are
realizing that innovation is coming
increasingly from outside of their own
entities and they need to create this
open campus type of environment where
that we're both can benefit
mm Jimmy if what with a lot of companies
helped them go from starts up to scale
up I mean what what the barriers that
still they're preventing more companies
keeping a lot of established businesses
really need to understand that their
chief asset could be their customers
they have the ability to provide
distribution audience reach and know
venture capitalist is going to give them
50 million euros sterling dollars
whatever to build that audience to reach
etc distribution and so really what you
have is startups which are revenue
generating algorithms they understand
something about how to make money in the
future their cars they need a highway
and so the way to construct it is put
the car on the highway but the challenge
is is where it gets tricky is that most
of those highways are the digital
players out in the valley and in the
world which has gone from analog to
digital
we're no longer living in a linear world
we're living in an exponential world if
you're running put your big company in
the box and if you're not living in an
exponential growth world in a digital
world you're getting further and further
behind from the competition so if you're
a bank number one and you think you can
Bank you compete with bank number two
you don't you actually compete with
Facebook mo Apple Amazon Google uber
Airbnb and so forth which are living in
a networked world driven by exponential
growth so the real problem is actually
the UK and Europe are creating
supernovae exits are entrepreneurs
cashing out to us technology firms and
making bundles of money to go buy houses
in Hampstead yes they are that's good
are the ecosystems which are where the
network effects go which is why Apple is
worth nearly a trillion are those
ecosystems platform companies with
network effects anywhere close to
becoming more based in the UK sadly it's
gay
much worse so just as we're cashing out
to us technology firms because the dirty
little secret is most of the European
venture community has really only one
play in their playbook and that's to
figure out which US technology firm
they're gonna sell you to if we could
get the bank's on the Royal Mail and the
telcos and the retailers to really take
seriously that they have to become
platforms with network effects we could
start to move the dial Katherine which
US tech company do you want to start
your company fascinating because there
is a kind of culture about
entrepreneurship that is very kind of go
get it and that scale element I'm not
sure we could have started the business
anywhere but here
weirdly in terms of talent in terms of
taking that kind of leap and in terms of
the country eccentricity of this as well
but in terms of scaling America does
kind of dangle a lot of kind of very
tempting things at an entrepreneur I'm
Jamal I know that you're looking kind of
scaling self-belief around the world and
we were just chatting about it before
and you know but it's not just America
we're also opening in Asia as well so
that was a very fascinating market
auction
shouldn't you be in LA New York San Fran
right now what are you doing here Ivan
bin yeah but one of my my my next aims
is to take her to South Africa in andele
but when I when I went to Beijing for a
week I had people in aides are saying we
want your content we love Western
culture but I'm in China and I love
YouTube so can we take some of your
videos and then spread it out there so
that's like another avenue that i want
to go down but i always keep that sort
of UK man sha with me is just like sort
of trying to showcase people before it
gets to the mainstream media that's like
my my main thing
of view starting a company is morally
superior there's something about the
agency of sorting your own company
taking on old industries do you do you
feel that with what you're doing that
there's a kind of a bigger mission
I never said everyone always says that
was taken on MTV and always aspired to
be like MTV when I was a little bit
younger but now it's sort of now I just
want to keep on building a platform that
can just grow to beyond belief like I
just hit 300 million views on my channel
so now I want to take it's like half a
billion and a billion and keep on
building that and take it other places
but I don't have any aims in saying I'm
going to be better than this company or
I'm taking over us to sort of just keep
on building it's a thing a lot of
conversations about about tech this
London versus Silicon Valley question
and clearly all clusters are different
and so on but you know what do you think
it would take for London to really move
ahead in that kind of global race to be
the Innovation Centre so there are
several aspects but speaking from my
experience because helix Nano is a
health tech company and I deal in this
sort of world of deep technology and
science I think one of the things that
we really need to get better at is
commercializing some of the amazing IP
that's coming out of our universities so
I saw an amazing statistic that you can
track back almost half of the revenue in
Silicon Valley to companies that came
out of Stanford and when you're there
you realize that Stanford is actually
the powerhouse of Silicon Valley and in
the UK we have a bunch of brilliant
universities generating a great deal of
IP but I think last year we filed for
0.2% of patents globally that's not good
enough
and the commercial terms that
universities give here are much much
worse so when entrepreneurs students
want to spin out companies and the
entrepreneurs the universities are not
being long-term greedy as they call it
in the u.s. they're not thinking
long-term they're taking a big chunk
upfront and sort of strangling these
startups before they even get off the
ground but it is improving there's a
there's other great stats in that in
that space that Stanford University
attracts more private investment each
year than Oxford Cambridge and Imperial
combined with having soft shows how open
Stanford is I think to to doing business
rolling as a as a big company are you
doing much with British universities how
does that work for you I'm actually
going to Stanford on Sunday week so that
might say something look at I think one
of the things we have to think about is
whether or not we want to cover all
bases or whether we want to place some
bets and I think one of the developments
that we've seen in the incubator and
innovators face recently has been the
development of some deeper tech spaces
and whether it be EdTech FinTech med
tech I think there's some evidence of
the British economy has significantly
benefited from industrial policy in the
last phase I think we want a kind of a
digital sector policy in this phase and
actually try and be champions at a
number of these things rather than come
second or third in lots of things you
know so these are you know opportunities
and challenges women in technology and I
read Katherine do you think there's an
obstacle do you think there's something
women on the stage there are lots of
women in the audience but as Martha said
it is a crisis and if you believe like
Ronan said the technology has changed
everything and that we are we need to
change as human beings our society needs
to move with that shift women cannot get
left behind in that and I certainly feel
that I
he rephrase that women's brains don't
work that way when it comes to
technology I heard that every single
week can you imagine something else that
you would say that about and you know
we've looked at the difference between
men and women and their ability to code
there's no difference in computational
thinking but it's huge difference in
comedones you trained you know thousands
of people in encoding in men and women
women do just as well as men on your
you're even asking this question you
raised it you raised it yes this is not
some number one it's not magic you know
and there is something about technology
that feels like it's magic the thing
that's affecting the entire world cannot
be owned by one person's and you know
women needs to be coding the products
that increasingly changing our lives and
affecting businesses and they need to be
founding those businesses as well and I
pretty damning that research is about to
come out for the launch of London
technology week about the states of
Women in Technology in London and you
could look at that really negatively or
certain ambition the UK could
potentially be the best place in the
world when it comes to women and
technology but we need female bc's I
think there are six female partner VCS
in Europe just because he doesn't know
who they are doesn't mean but there's
not about six dozen so I could give you
a list of the female partners there's a
fewer female VCS who are partners that
have set up their own firm but the money
is there in the hands of the women and
so forth but the way it's true we back
about 40% women and our venture fund
we're not trying right we're just simply
doing that I'm I'm almost certain I
would love to create some visibility
about this that there is genuinely a
belief that women's ideas aren't as big
or ambitious and changed the world ish
and I hear that a lot you know
the important thing though is that and
I'm sure everybody in this room doesn't
need you know convincing about this you
never win by playing by somebody else's
rules ever ever this whole concept of
breaking through somebody else's glass
ceiling own the glass ceiling right then
if you want to break through it if you
want to make a new glassy whatever you
want to do but own the glass ceiling
that's why we should be encouraging
women to set up their own business
rather than trying to get on the boards
of public companies it just honestly is
not the route to fulfillment of any kind
but the world is becoming feminine it
really is so if you take all of the good
characteristics transparency group
collaboration and call them feminine
right they're becoming increasingly
important in management and leadership I
think something like only eleven percent
of Silicon Valley executives of women do
you think this is an area where London
really could definitively beat the
valley by being a much more equal fair
place than than California I mean
absolutely in a way we are starting so
we could set the terms and we could set
the agenda there are a lot of women in
Silicon Valley but you notice that they
are in peripheral sort of roles less so
in technical and decision-making roles
and more so in supporting roles and I
think it would be great to change that
all right second home we started with a
blank canvas and almost half of the CEOs
and founders there are women so it shows
you you can you can do it okay you know
you with what you're seeing on on
YouTube you know and the different ways
in which people can express themselves
you know how she thinks of diversity is
coming to life in in in your world I
find there being diverse viral content
is just by the people I film so if I if
I do a video with
Little Mix or Tetsu and I'll get influx
of females on on the channel but then
it's just about keeping them in the
channel in the ecosystem and then once
they're in an ecosystem I've then had
them apply for jobs and now social media
manager SB TV predominately was it was a
Mel that was doing there but now it's a
few milder and I was because they watch
the channel and it was just me expanding
the sort of meaner of music - we put a
bunch on mmm fantastic well I could talk
to these guys all day I'm probably going
to but where we're just about out of
time here we talked about everything
from women to London to what's wrong and
what's right I've accidentally maybe
offended Katherine and sorry about that
but it's been a fascinating conversation
so thank you all and thank you to the
great panelists